so with some of the medicinal stuff when
I was doing a little research for this I
you can see all kinds of crazy things I
mean you can see people that say
literally I cured brain cancer with just
by night you know using CBD oil or
something like that
and then you could see people that it
helped with pain or it help with nausea
I got my appetite back I mean really the
gamut of everything what's like the most
amazing case that you've ever seen of
helping you know something really
serious like cancer or Parkinson's or
something like that well I have a good
friend had Crohn's has Crohn's disease
and you know he really credits cannabis
with giving him his life back I mean he
was suffering tremendously for many many
years and another friend of mine has a
young niece who had a brain tumor and
she her family was treating it with the
Rick Simpson oil and what's that it's a
it's I've never tried it myself but it's
it's a it's Rick Simpson developed this
method of making this concentrated oil
and you can find directions on how to
make it yourself just like what they
give very young kids right right does
this have something to do with what
happened in New Jersey and Christy got
and all that because I think he didn't
want to pass it but then got sort of
guilty to it which made no sense anyway
what I think wasn't he just allowing the
CBD stuff yeah I try but I think that
you know I've seen a lot of people who
really believe that it's helped them for
so many different things even if it's
just you know I have a bad back and I
rub a topical on my on my back and I
feel better you know it's not always
about getting stoned yeah I'm so you
know and and for a while I was
volunteering in a
Cannabis physician's office and you know
different I would see different patients
and and how they were using the medicine
I mean it's it's great for any kind of a
your neuro neuropathy you know any kind
of nerve pain it it it's provides great
relief for that and you know breast
cancer there's been studies showing that
I mean they've shown that it can really
just kill certain cancer cells I mean to
me that's incredible so for the people
that would say this is they still have
this stigma attached to it you know I
think a lot of them they don't want
people to even deal with their own pain
its unfathomable to me
that if someone across from me had
cancer or at Parkins in there a Taser
whatever it is what right what I have to
say well you can't do that to yourself
to alleviate your pain right what do you
think goes on in the mind of that person
I really I cannot imagine again I think
it's fear and and misinformation and
that's why thank you so much again for
having me here because I think it's it's
it's so important to come out and speak
on the topic I know I'm fighting a
stereotype you know but I do not
consider myself a STONER and I am very
productive you know so I think that's
the funny part there's money to be made
here yeah for a lot of people it's
happening in Colorado right now it's
happening across California so this is
these are serious business people right
yeah it's like the new California Gold
Rush in a way anyway you have to be
willing to sort of put your butt on the
line I suppose yeah for hopefully not
too much longer and you will we'll see I
mean I think that that energy is
definitely going in the right direction
and hopefully we'll get some regulations
in place especially here in LA because
you know we we are the center of this
industry and we should take a leadership
role in creating regulations that could
be you know used other places as well
yeah and what I really like to see is
an industry that encourages
entrepreneurship encourages small
business owners and encourages
creativity and not a monopoly and that's
really another goal of the task force is
to allow that to happen
you know really bring everyone in out of
the shadows and and operate legitimately
yeah so I know you don't buy the the
gateway drug thing but where do you
stand on legalization of all drugs in
general because I think this is probably
one of the places where the argument
gets tough where suddenly you say I'm
all in on weed and then there's probably
a lot of people that say well I'm just
all in on everything and then you could
get what I would think even though I'm
basically for legalization of most stuff
pretty much I think people could make a
more sound case and say if you legalize
all of this stuff people are gonna just
be trying all kinds of really crazy
don't think so I mean okay I'm still
sort of vacillating where I stay yeah
well okay
drugs there are many drugs that aren't
legal now that people try it doesn't
limit people's ability to access it
right they can get them right you're
risking going to prison you know so I
mean legalizing all drugs I do believe
that there are drugs that don't have any
real health benefit and are dangerous
but I don't think criminalizing activity
that way is is the right answer you know
if you're trying to fight addiction
putting someone in prison is not going
to solve that preventing them from
having a productive life is not going to
solve that yeah and what a crazy system
that someone could try to alleviate
their pain because of a chronic disease
and our the way we deal with them is by
putting them in jail right yeah I mean
you know veterans right now are really
fighting to get access to medical
marijuana I mean the fact that
they've had to fight to be able to treat
their PTSD with cannabis is crazy you
know I mean I think they've earned that
yeah all right well we we have to wrap
up so first off I'm very happy about
this this is very exciting I think I've
gotten it already but give me your give
me your final cell give me your 62nd
cell on why all this is important for
our so we can clip it for Facebook
perfectly why is making this legal and
doing all this just give me it give me
the elevator pitch cannabis medicine is
you know cannabis is an amazing plant it
has so many health benefits it has saved
many lives to to to make it illegal or
to continue to keep it illegal it just
hurts it hurts us as a society it hurts
individuals I mean it's just bad all
around I mean this is this is um for me
it's about really getting people to
understand that I'm not a bad person you
know I'm here to provide products that
people enjoy and that people benefit
from and you know it's time to for LA
especially to to accept this industry
and to create some framework for us to
to to be successful yeah yeah I think
you nailed it well as I told you before
we started you know I spent a lot of
time here talking about terrorism and
politics and jihadism and all kinds of
crazy stuff so this was an absolute
pleasure this will help me relaxing
after the show so I thank you for that
and you guys can follow along with
angels doing it's Ruby dooby bakes calm
right and she just signed up for Twitter
so give her a follow at Ruby dooby bakes
and it's also a true because Lakes on
Instagram how was that pimping pretty
good
that was pretty good all right thanks
for watching and we'll do it again next
week